uh speaking of which you're single
mm-hmm so what does your ideal man look
like ideal guy
um I would say I I like guys that are
super conservative
um ideally in the U.S because that's
kind of an issue I'm like moving so
ideally he'd be in the U.S
um what kind of money does he need to
make uh maybe like in US Dollars like I
don't know 40 50. 40 50k yeah I mean I
don't I don't know everyone's gonna say
I'm cap it depends what he does
okay well let's start out it is what he
does this isn't we're not trying to
diagnose you and break you down but
you're very successful yeah okay I know
you do more than six figures we're not
going to talk about it okay uh but
you're how tall are you I'm six foot oh
my God I know and you got heels on I
like guys you know I'm comfortable with
my height
I smell like I'm comfortable with my
weight no yeah but you're tall yes yeah
no I was thinking about it I'm like yeah
because I'm the average height in
America that's what five nine okay so
right but to my eyes short but we we've
all done the numbers on six foot tall
six figures six pack abs right the
probabilities like less than a percent
yeah and that's why I'm like I gotta go
like because because every year your
income is going up right the more
successful your brand becomes right
right and you're 26 you're at the
perfect age right so is the question is
because it'll get exposed you have to
find a man that's going to be
comfortable with being exposed to being
married to you right because your last
relationship
um
yeah you know they're yeah they went
after them they did yeah is that why you
guys broke up or no no I
I say he dumped me I
I broke up with him I'd like to set that
okay okay but but no it was I just think
our backgrounds are a bit too different
I just couldn't see it like long term
somebody said 40 50k stop the cat
[Laughter]
I said my okay just so you guys know
Pearl's talking about moving back to the
yes we're all we're all like move to
Vegas with Vegas now she's right when
you look at Las Vegas from the outside
in it's like the bottom of hell where
Lucifer lives right okay it's not but it
does look like that but if you move to
Miami
that's expensive okay it's expensive on
the Strip but outside the strip is very
affordable now Florida is a good option
but I think Vegas is better for you more
people come in I'm going to shoot for
you we need you on our side to the west
coast represent west side right but
here 100K you're doing really well in
Vegas really well but the average income
for a man
in America is 51 000 right right a black
man's 41 000 right so you say 40 50 you
got to stop the cap because it's not
gonna work I'm not saying you're lying
but you're just guessing because you
don't know but imagine going to Miami
and London London's expensive okay New
York London okay Miami a little bit less
than London but it's expensive okay so
now you're in the top one percent and
he's got to be six feet tall because
with you got heels on you got
conservative heels on it's an inch and a
half yeah now now how tall are you uh
like six one two roughly and he's got to
learn he has to be able to take it to
the hoop because you're gonna you're
gonna dunk on them right I mean because
you played basketball yes yes I do so
what if he can't hoop I mean I don't
care you're gonna embarrass him I mean
well I've I've done that before it
didn't I forgot as a girl you're
supposed to like let the guy win oh how
embarrassing I know well you know I have
done that where I was seeing someone and
I beat them in basketball and I I
actually I would say girls let them win
like you shouldn't do that I yeah what
what what was it what position did you
play forward I was a center oh my gosh
yeah could you dunk no I was too I could
touch I was I could touch 9 10 which is
like two inches from Ram that like my
Peak I don't think I could jump that
high now do you think you could have
went pro yeah I could have I had a pro
contract offered to me in the fall if
the YouTube thing didn't take off I
probably would have taken it wow yeah
because that's what um because I took
three years off
um I worked in sales that's why I give
the 40 50 a year because that's what I
used to make so I'm like is it real like
because I think like would I date
someone that worked the same job I used
to work I'm like well it was a good job
I respect the job yeah but when was that
how many years ago uh I don't know two
three years ago
but you were Milwaukee yes yes yeah I
mean it's not expensive to live in
Milwaukee yeah yeah right in fact
they're they're losing population
are they really yeah yeah I like the
city it's too bad well I mean that's
okay so so it's official she's moving to
Las Vegas what day I'm just kidding so
no but you're are you
how are you preparing yourself because
this is get this gets asked by women
right you said you're single yes are you
and I I hate this when women say this
but I'm not looking are you looking
uh honestly you're busy but are you
keeping an eye out yeah do you check DMs
I do check DM okay okay the issue now is
I want I want to date someone in the U.S
because I don't see myself long term in
the UK what nationality I get black
white or other anything it does look
really I haven't I've never gone for
like um guys that are like Asian but
mostly it's because they're like a lot
shorter than me you know like like a lot
I'm actually okay and they're a little
shorter I don't really mind okay okay
but yeah do you want a conservative guy
yes hey how many kids do you want to
have
um
said like ideally for
um but four kids ideally okay but at
least but I'm okay with as long as I
have two I'm okay oh my God 40K kind of
girlfriend you gotta make 250 a year no
that's good so you want to be married
then yeah okay okay so you see the fear
shifting gears see the fear we talked
about this earlier a men in America
and the fear of us right now and I look
at it from a business perspective if you
take 100 marriages 51 or divorced
correct and out of those 51 75 to 80 the
women are filing for divorce and I
always get well why are they filing why
are they filing and what's what's funny
they say that but then I talk to some of
the women and they're like um I just I
just wasn't happy I just I just it there
was no energy I'm like what well well
marriage in 2023 isn't marriage it is
not marriage today like it's something
else like we can't we can't call it
marriage if you can like what what is
marriage it's supposed to be for better
for worse for richer and poor for poor
for sickness and health not until I felt
like leaving right okay and so it's like
when you have a contract that is
supposed to be for life and now anyone
can leave for any reason I just think it
like marriage today isn't marriage it's
just at this point a long-term
relationship do you do you feel women
are rewarded to get divorced oh yeah oh
my gosh yes yes yes yes yes and I I
especially learned this through the
divorce documentary that I'm doing when
I when I interview these men that are
like getting like actually completely
wrecked by these women oh my gosh
um but what surprised me in uh London
was this whole with with the you're
doing this documentary right and I saw
you run and I won't say the podcast but
I wasn't a fan of the two Knuckleheads
um but you had brought up that in London
if you get divorced and you have
children all the woman has to do
is go to the court and say that she was
abused yes and what happens she gets a
free lawyer and she can kick him out she
can one get him arrested by the police
and kick him out of the house that he
pays with no evidence no evidence and
then get a restraining order on him
which are actually really easy to get in
the U.S from what I understand too for
women so essentially one of the guys I
talked to was like literally paying the
mortgage on a house that he was kicked
out of oh yeah with the kids that he
couldn't see and that's that was there
here that was there yeah I just
interviewed someone also the other day
whose ex is trying to make his kid like
trans or whatever and he can't do
anything she still has primary custody
well so I'm from Washington State
Seattle yeah they just passed the law
because the difference from the States
from the UK and London is it the UK how
would you call it London London okay uh
the United States is one of the only
countries in the world where one of two
I think where each state operates like
its own country right because United
States so all the yeah the federal law
and the state laws you're from Chicago
right Born and Raised so in Washington
state the governor just passed a policy
that says if you're
child wants to do a gender reassignment
surgery and you say no and they run away
from home the state can take your kids
from you
wow so imagine the state coming to your
house and saying well we're taking your
kids because Bobby wants to be Becky
isn't that crazy it's so crazy and then
the father has no say or the mom in this
situation I think when men have children
they are not their kids I think there is
no way to really have a child and have
that be your kid because you are always
at the whim of the mother and if she
wants to be spiteful and you just have
to hope you picked a good one and that
she didn't especially like in the UK the
way it's set up but here at different
state to state but like genuinely
marriage there's a lot of ways to
protect yourself but the issue too is
that they keep making laws like to get
around like basically still chaining men
to marriage so it's like like the guys
won't get married but then they'll say
if a girl lives with you for a certain
amount of time then she has like marital
right it's like that whatever legal way
like men try to walk away they just try
to make a new law to force them to be
married so so what they're doing now in
the states with prenups aren't even
holding up in court right yeah so what I
did
Nevada is a non-common law marriage
state right so some states if you live
together two years seven years six years
five years you're automatically it's
common law so if you break up she gets
it's treated like you were married right
she she's entitled to some of your
earnings Nevada's not that way
that's why I tell these guys and I'm not
I'm not against marriage hear me out I
think the laws need to be revamped yeah
I agree don't you because women talk
about equality
but but they have more rights than men
do they do like if I don't want a kid
and you have a kid I gotta pay for it
right and and I'm not about abortions
hear me out but this is an example you
have more rights than I do if you want
an abortion I don't want you have an
abortion you're going to get an abortion
I have no say yeah and if if you have
unproductive if you have unprotected sex
with a girl like I I have abortion as a
as a cop-out there's Plan B as a cap out
there's adoption as a cop-out like you
don't have any Say in any of that no and
you have 41 different contraceptives as
a woman right it gives you the
opportunity to be a 304 right correct
but I I think what's happening now is
men are starting to wake up and I'm all
about a marriage I tell guys look do the
ceremony
you know muja state that doesn't have
common law marriage did the ceremony get
married do the ring if you want don't
sign the contract right and and what the
first response I get from women is oh
well that's not fair what do you mean is
not fair so now what you're doing is a
business person
I have
four million dollars
as a business person you want me to go
into business with a person I have a 51
chance that that business is going to
fail and then if it fails they're
getting 70 ownership people say no it's
50 50. no it isn't because let's talk
about that you're going to get half my
net worth
I'm gonna have to move out of the house
I'm gonna have to pay spousal support
child support you should take care of
your children regardless and I got to
pay the mortgage and I got to move into
a shitty little apartment you see what I
mean that's not fair that's an equal but
then it's like the reason women I
believe are mad is because they don't
have leverage
now the men have men aren't leaving
marriages you know most men and not I
wouldn't say high value men I'd say the
average dude
they actually have to literally see
their woman cheat on them if they found
out that sheet some of them still stay
men don't really leave yeah I think men
are more like they believe more in like
Duty than women do right because women
we're very loyal we're loyal to our
feelings and those can change every day
where men are more like loyalty that's
like why like military I think is more
for men than women it's because it gives
them like the structure the discipline
um like in a way like the Loyalty you
know yeah
um what was that uh
how do you feel about that comment
men love unconditionally women don't I
think that's true can you elaborate on
that
um I mean if I date a guy and he's
unemployed for three years I'm not gonna
love him anymore like I mean just being
honest like most girls are gonna go and
I think most dads would probably advise
their daughter to go I mean minus he's
going through like maybe three years too
soon but I don't know I mean that's a
pretty long time yeah that is a long
time I mean like there's so many jobs
here in Vegas it's hard to get employed
right you know but it's like men it's
not the same like they'll stick oh my
gosh the men now they stick it out
through everything their wife won't be
sleeping with them they stay I mean
granted they're kind of forced from the
government to stay that's why their wife
their wife gets like super fat they're
like all right I'm rolling with the
punches I might cheat but I'm rolling
with the punches
um right they they literally they stay
through everything like women don't yeah
that's that's true and I think that
that's that's the problem a lot of you
know we we get locked in yeah I mean I
was married for 16 and a half years
right and then at the end it was like
roommates but I stuck it out for the
kids but then it was like I wasn't happy
I tried as long as I could
um so but we're good friends from a
distance right there's no ill will as
many of you you know I was just banned
on Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible